i say yes to stuff why not and so i just
go running at things
as we leave the perfection of childhood
the hypnosis and the brainwashing begins
when you're in all the muck and you're
just walking in muck and walking in muck
and walking the muck
you don't see that if you look off to
the left of the muck there's a sidewalk
brother
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you you've got
michael jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven
practical steps you can take to change
your life for the better
okay let's kick it off with step number
one do whatever it takes
what is it that you understand that
makes you so successful that you think
other people
are missing i don't know
it's necessarily other people are
missing it i'm i'm willing to do
whatever it takes
like create a a situation where it feels
like life or death
billions or body bags billions of body
banks yeah no but
in all seriousness that i think is the
distinguishing
characteristic because all four of the
businesses
there were all turned out to be
successes but
if i didn't put it into that extra gear
i think none of them would have made it
like i i really think you have to
you have to be willing to to go all the
way
how do you pull that off though like the
first time i get it because it really is
i know you left the banking
uh you didn't exactly have a safety net
and so the first one really is sort of
billions of body bags but
after that i mean you've had some huge
wins yeah how do you recapture that
i always figure out a way to put myself
in a position where
it can't not work and so yeah the first
one it was not only quitting
but i also put every dollar in my bank
account into that first company did you
have kids at that point
yeah so what do you just have involved i
just had a kid like the number of people
that want to be entrepreneurs that come
up to me and they say look i've got this
litany of things you know i'm married
now i have kids i can't really
do this how did you position yourself
financially
and emotionally to pull that one off i
just convinced myself that
i would do this for a you know a year or
two give it a real go
because you had that much saved up or
the
idea was to take everything i saved
invested in the company
take a salary and then but i still
needed to raise
capital to kind of continue on and so
i hope that i'd be able to do that and
if i if i was able to then i'd
be able to sustain worst case wasn't
able to raise money
had no more money in savings and had to
go back into the workforce
did i think that i can get back in like
was i
you know past the point where of no
return and i thought no you know i'm
seven years
into my career worst case i can go back
and get it
get a you know normal job again
but it was that was too much of a safety
net no you could always go back
it was investing every penny of savings
into the business that was the real
catalyst for making sure that it worked
and then in the subsequent business it
was less about the money that was at
risk and more
friends and family money so every
relative
every friend everybody i knew pretty
much had a stake in the startup
and i just didn't want to disappoint all
the people that i love and care about
you know but so that drove me more than
anything
step number two take on anything with
henry rollins
i'm a crass opportunist in that i'm
really not good at any of the stuff i do
i'm a jackass of all tirades um
when i i was doing music at some point
in the 80s hollywood director started
calling me
hey you're that crazy guy can you act
i'm like yeah can you pay
cause i i i this top ramen noodle diet's
killing me
i'll try anything and so i started my
own little publishing company in the 80s
to write my dumb little books
and i stayed with it started doing the
talking shows stayed with that
at one point hey you want to do a
voice-over yeah i'll put my
voice over anything over rice over
noodles and over your
over your ad and so i say yes to stuff
why not and so i just go running at
things
and so what am i i'm not only am i an
american
but i i'm an americanist and
not really a survivalist as much as one
who seeks to prevail
and i i think one of the things i
luckily
guys like me have to do everything three
times before we get it right
thankfully i know that so i know that i
have to get up early and and try it five
times
because the eight-year-old will be able
to get past it in two times so i have to
be on my feet longer but at least i know
it and so i just go at stuff
and it served me very well and that my
resume is pretty varied
and uh i have a pretty interesting life
i get to do different stuff and have a
bit of access
because i just said yeah i'll try that i
mean
why would i hold back step number three
get a different vantage point with david
goggins
i used to look at my life from a
different vantage point and when you're
when you're in
all the muck and you're just walking in
muck and walking in muck and walking the
muck
you don't see that if you look off to
the left of the muck there's a sidewalk
brother
get off get off of it you have your head
down looking in this muck
once i saw the sidewalk got the sidewalk
i got a little break
and i got a different vantage point and
then from the sidewalk i found a cliff
then i found a mountain i got way up
high on top of my life and looked back
down on it and said okay
i gotta figure this out man i'm not
going anywhere
i'm starting to lie i'm starting like so
when you have a messed up foundation
i started lying about everything i
wanted people to like me i wanted to be
accepted
in some society of life some social
society and i
i was like man this isn't the right way
i messed up here i messed up here i
messed up everywhere
and so i realized the worst thing that
happened to me is i lost myself
i never had myself i never found myself
had no self-esteem
so i knew through working out and
through learning
because it took a lot for me to learn
also i started finding self-esteem once
i found that
that's when doors started opening up i
started i stopped caring about people
that what they thought being judged wow
if i say this if i started right now
or you make fun of me i stopped caring
about that and that's my life started
really changing for me
slowly but surely also if you want to
have confidence motivation and self-love
check out my 254 series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below i'm not exactly quitting
but here's this thing that happened and
he said it's your shot
i said yeah he said take it you can
outwork
anybody remember how badass they are
saturn
was not going to impact my life and i
didn't care about it
step number four have patience with gary
vaynerchuk
the lack of patience bro i mean it's
crazy to me that literally patience and
insecurity
is 90 of the unlock for everybody
listening right now
their mom [ __ ] on them their whole life
and said they're going to be a loser so
they believe it
because that's what parenting is uh and
they just want to have a
you know maserati now and they'll do
whatever it takes to do it and so
they'll take
they did something like how many kids
are doing something smart like doing a
good retail arbitrage
on amazon right now and making a hundred
thousand dollars by buying on alibaba
and selling in amazon took a year and a
half three years to get good at it but
now we're taking every profit and buying
some rando cryptocurrency
because they're playing the lotto
that's just real this is what's going on
in our society we have to have these
conversations you're seeing big gains
fast like let me jump like there's a kid
who spent
three years being disciplined and
getting good at retail arbitrage it's a
real skill to have an eye for like what
to buy in china
how to set up on amazon properly how to
run ad like it's a skill
yeah they did it for three years
meticulously they made 13 000 and 47
now they finally are making 300 000 and
they could be on their way to 10 million
yet they've chosen to kind of stop jump
on the short-term bandwagon
of buying some weird cryptocurrency
hoping it's the next
bitcoin or ethereum i'm just seeing that
every day
and i'm just like it's it's being
predicated on
short term yeah you hear one story zucks
did it
instagram sold in 550 days for now on
that's why everybody started an app
company
to follow the leadership completely
predicated on short term i went the
other way
while everybody was blowing up i decided
to build an agency
boring ass shitty ass business in the
prime of my career
when everything was going for me in
silicon valley
i'm proud of that step number five
become unreasonable with robin sharma
the very nature of being a human being
is we are built to progress we know that
the human brain craves novelty
and we are most alive we have the most
energy we are most
intimate with our best selves when we're
progressing towards our mighty mission
so i think we all want i think what's
happened on the planet right now is
there's been a great seduction and a
great brainwashing
when we are kids we want we want to be
astronauts
we want to be billionaires we want to be
history makers
we want to do all our dreams and then
and
we stand in awe and wonder and we're
full of curiosity and we're loving
and we're passionate we're strong we're
not afraid to be ourselves
but as we leave the perfection of
childhood the hypnosis and the
brainwashing begins our well-intentioned
parents say
oh you want to be an astronaut you want
to start a business
when you grow up you want to paint like
joe michelle basquiat
be reasonable and
george bernard's job said it better than
i ever could he said the reasonable man
adapts himself to the world the
unreasonable one persists in adapting
the world to himself
therefore all progress depends on the
unreasonable man
so that's our nature but our parents
give us limitation based on their
limited psychology and their emotional
patterns that they learn from their
parents then we go to school and we're
taught to live in a box think in a box
dress like everyone else don't sing too
loudly don't dream too big don't be too
passionate
and then our peers do the same thing to
us and then society says oh
genius is the realm of genetics not
everyday people which has been
dismissed by some very good science you
know i mean the ten thousand hour rule
that we all know
from florida state university professor
anders erickson
it just confirmed so much so i do think
we all want
i think what's happened is we've as
we've left who we truly are
we've contracted and now it's all about
staying safe in the world versus going
out there and
letting our brilliant our primal genius
shine
and a lot of people just have stuff that
pain of disappointment
and their doubt really deep inside and
they just are addicted to distraction
and escapes because they don't want to
deal with their
potential that they've denied step
number six build discipline with thomas
frank
in book five of meditations aurelius
writes at dawn when you have trouble
getting out of bed
tell yourself i have to go to work as a
human being
what do i have to complain of if i'm
going to do what i was born for the
things i was brought into the world to
do
or is this what i was created for to
huddle under the blankets and stay
warm but it's nicer here so you were
born to feel
nice instead of doing things and
experiencing them don't you see the
plants the birds the ants and spiders
and bees going about their individual
tasks putting the world in order as best
they can
and you're not willing to do your job as
a human being why aren't you running to
do what your nature demands
but we have to sleep sometime agreed but
nature set a limit on that
as it did on eating and drinking and
you're over that limit you've had more
than enough of that
but not of working there you're still
below your quota you don't love yourself
enough
or you'd love your nature too and what
it demands of you people who
love what they do wear themselves down
doing it they even forget to wash or eat
do you have less respect for your own
nature than the engraver does for
engraving the dancer for dance the miser
for money or the social climber for
status
when they're really possessed by what
they do they'd rather stop eating and
sleeping than give up practicing their
arts
he's telling you to respect your choice
of path in life enough that you consider
it to be your very nature
to be instinct just as spiders and bees
and ants get up every day and are driven
by their instincts
so should you be driven by the actions
that are demanded by your goals
if yesterday you decided you wanted to
get up early so you could work on your
goals but now you're lying in bed and
you feel
comfortable and you don't want to get up
then you need to focus your mind on your
nature
on the path you've chosen and let that
override your current desire
other aspects of the art of gaining
self-discipline like exercises for
building grit
or systems that commit you to things
ahead of time are important but they
take a back step to this one key insight
for marcus aurelius respecting your work
as your very nature
and tailoring your decisions and actions
in accordance with that was the most
important part of building discipline
and step number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is make a decision with bob proctor
i'm going to share something with you
that could change the course of your
life
could make everything so much better to
do this to explain it properly i'm going
to tell you a little story
it goes way back 57 years
a man gave me this book he said bob do
exactly what i tell you
and you can have anything you want now
when he said that i was flat broke
i had six thousand dollars in debt i was
only earning four thousand dollars a
year
the prospects of thing getting better
were pretty slim
i had two months high school formal
education i had absolutely no business
experience i was not in a good spot but
he said listen there are reasons why you
can't win
bob he said if you do what i tell you
and study this book
is you're going to figure out how you
can now this is napoleon hill's book
think and grow rich he spent his whole
life studying 500 of the world's most
successful
individuals and he found there was a
golden shred running through their life
and that's what's in this book
i've never stopped reading it i then
found a condensed narration of the book
by earl nightingale where earl took and
he condensed the whole thing
and he put it on a long playing record
and i would listen to that and listen to
it and listen to it
in fact i had started my own company and
i used to play the records
to the sales people every morning well
one morning
it was very early just finished the
sales meeting just finished playing
earl's record
and i said at the end of the meeting i
said man i'd really love to meet him
one of the sales people said no you
wouldn't because what do you mean i
wouldn't
he said if you really wanted to meet him
you'd go and meet him and i thought you
know something you're right
i got on the phone and i got an
appointment with earl langdale
now that wasn't an easy thing to do earl
was the most listened to man in the
history of the broadcasting industry at
the time
earl nightingale lloyd conan started the
night galcona corporation who literally
started the personal development
business as we know it today
in recorded fashion he was considered
the dean of personal motivation
there was probably a couple of million
people that would have loved to sat down
with him
but i got the appointment at the end of
the meeting i had a wonderful time there
when i was leaving i said earl
what is the big deal what is the real
secret of light to
making things happen well he said there
isn't any secret to success bob he said
it's a
simple matter of figuring out what you
absolutely love to do
and then make a decision to dedicate
your life to it
then every day you're going to be doing
what you love to do so the problem with
most people is they
never decide what they love to do and
they don't make a decision to dedicate
their life to anything they just go from
one thing to the next
now i've got a special bonus clip on how
to take more action that i think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the question
of the day i want to know where do you
need to make a decision
in your business or life let me know put
it down in the comments below and if you
made it this far in a video you're still
here watching i want to celebrate you
because believe nation we don't just
watch videos we
do something about it so that's you and
you commit you promise you're gonna take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
cause i wanna celebrate you hope without
action
leads to pain and suffering watching
videos like this
is not enough it might give you hope but
hope that is not tied to action and you
doing something
will mean you never accomplish your
goals the answer is always action
it's hope and then action and when that
doesn't work out more action and when
that doesn't work out
more action so a couple years ago i was
in new york and i was meeting with my
agents
and one of them said what am i trying to
do what's what's my
vision what's my mission what i'm trying
to accomplish and i said i wanted to
spread belief i wanted to spread hope
and he jumped all over me about the hope
like you want to spread hope
hope's not enough you can't just do hope
and and i remember walking away like
what's he talking
hope is so important if you don't have
hope how are you going to
believe in yourself to go chase
something down without hope you got
nothing
right without hope and belief you got
nothing
where i realize the difference in the
thinking is the usage of the word is
people hope
things will happen it's not having hope
in something
it's hoping that it's gonna happen and
then they sit on their bed
sit on their couch sit at home and do
nothing that kind of hope
that's not a strategy hope and belief is
your first step
it's your first entry point in you have
hope that things will happen
but then you gotta get up and do
something right
and so figuring out that message when i
was talking to my agent didn't come to
you right away in the moment
because at the same time as much as i'm
filled with hope and belief
in humanity and what we can all do i'm
work
right i'm taking action i'm making three
to four videos every day
we haven't had a day in the past five
years where video hasn't gone up
every single day i don't know what that
consecutive streak is but it's long
it's big i'm working my face off every
day
in the achievement of my mission but i
also love hope and belief
it's why i have this channel so i have
my other channels i want i want to be
around people who've done a lot more i
want to learn from
the greats i want to learn from people
who know more than me and when i see
that it gives me hope that it's possible
it gives me belief that it's possible
that if they can do it i can do it too
but you still have to do it the ability
to do it versus
actually executing and doing it are two
very different things
right the difference gap is going to be
the action and so
yes i want you to have hope i think it's
important but it's not the only thing
you got to make sure you turn that hope
and not just rely on the strategy but
you're doing the daily work to chase
down your dreams
[Music]
if you want more wisdom on how to build
your dream life check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there the biggest
poison in us is regret
it's poison and i push so hard